and this is the wired autocomplete
interview
[Music]
what does itsy
means to have to have to have it means
to have in Korean we have everything you
guys expect in us so all in us that's
what we say all the time what is Itsy
Trust
[Music]
yeah me too means trust in Korean so
what is
really hard three two oh wait wait wait
there is that sir guys okay okay
we come here to promote our treasure
album oh yeah
dance to learn actually our dance not
too easy
but sneakers really
yes who
joined let's see first first who joined
it first
actually the last member who joined the
Itsy is
the four of us have been together at
once so there is not a first member who
is this video oh it's this video what do
you think me
first of all
it is all visual member yeah that's
right recently my visual pick is
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
my pick is Leah really yes yes
nobody nobody nobody who is the
170.
70 centimeters centimeters
let's see can itsy speak Japanese
I really can't
[Music]
from yeah
we don't have a lexic we have a light
like Wing very special because we are
special yes yes because we're special we
created another
State yeah wing all right
can it see Drive oh I can't I can't oh
we can
and it's the rock can we see wrap show
[Music]
does it see
wear glasses fake glasses as a fashion
we like glasses yeah
fashion glasses can it see play
instruments
our voice is an instrument yeah
okay so how Etsy I'm excited how it's
the members were discovered first of all
she attended to the
audition she's a TV star yeah TV yes
audition
Yuna and I have
two other concerts another concert
Etsy how many
members
one two one two three four five three
the five members how to write
Etsy in Korean
how to write it's in Korean this is
really important yeah
some people misspell it some Korean so
sad they spell it too
yeah the actual you have to have a
double shield under the double shield
two of these is wrong no wrong no this
is right yes guys if you just think one
more time you can be correct first
good luck
or just safety
where are
itsy members from you're from Korea
Korea
[Music]
when is it's the album coming out
November 30 coming soon
Chester is coming
the next
where was wannabe it see
Korea movie yes
oh actually my favorite music video is
swipe oh
it is really have a young Vibe it's mine
is sneakers
for me to pick wannabe and sneakers
my favorite music video is wannabe my
name is
going on tour so we have a more concert
on 2023 so the word for it
oh final what are eating
animals and cats I've been told yeah
rabbit and Cat fans think I am a cat
hand sign oh three two one
lyrics
this was so much fun we'd love to do
this again and Chester is out now so
please go check it out this one is
[Music]
foreign